お前たち男は化粧すると思うか俺は知ってるんだよ
イヴァン時代はな男でも化粧するこれも常識なんだ僕はでいつまでもこんなすっぴん
エイヴァリーもいかないんで今日は自分でメイクをしてみようと思いますちょっと
恥ずかしながら頑張って薬局でねー
消費をかけたわけですよ化粧品用これは何でも工事
スペインがハワイらしい愛らしいこんな女
の目のつけまつけまあ他にポンポンでするポンくんまで溶け込む音流ハーフ顔のチーク
じゃあ一体ハーフ顔のチークリップ美容液桜も色のビッグピキッとアイライナー
7色に来鍋倉グリーナぱっちり目の音愛からファンデーションこれはね
ファンデーションですというわけで私の部屋の下見雀牌と友達がいるんだけど
私がね綺麗なお化粧して驚かせに行くの
やるぞ折り合えずを捧げ朝日さんの動画見てを偽証ので研究をする各現実の女ちょっと
前気がなくなっちゃってさぁ
しりとりで眉毛をちょっと整えようとしたら全部なくなっちゃったはずじゃ早速園って
いうことです
これでもう朝比奈動画5を見てるからね大腿部なんてまずはサンデーしょんですこれも
出てったんだよ指にねちょっと取りくらい金一番言って朝日なんか言ってたって方に
行こうで打って
2個見つけるで肌身なぜかせるね大事とても大丈夫
化粧このにもうファンデーションからの本田勝決まってる理由はこれで鼻だけ地は関西
はチーク夏熱流あー顔のチークを築きましょう
ブラシで適量を含ませ手の甲でいるの月組ブラッシュ持ってないわ
歯ブラシで代表しましょういろんな色があるブービーや夏やれ
月チークをすっかり肌になじませていきますいい感じだぴまあなどこれ着てんじゃねー
ています
かわいいために朝したんだとこの場合は多分先にアイライナー
アイライナーをつけますアイライナーがボスなに効果母は以来なって良かったこれが
ぐっんですか
バッハ間違えたか染まったんだが科学のレスは今こそ
ねえ感じ感じこれいいんじゃねこれじゃはアイライナーは熱いだと思いますもう
理由は分ジャズ口紅な次になりましょうさくらんぼ色の口目でステージ
ネクターが口紅もおかしくないっ
パッ
んかー
まじかいい感じだもう一息だマネー系がでもツァイから手間や木を書きましょうアイ
カラーのこの茶色いの使って眉毛をかけましょう
カペキッズこのまま目までいきましょうつ目はちょっとラブリーな感じでしたよ
ピンクで朝日さんの朝日さんもいい
朝日さんどうかスラントもうちょっとチークがねたぶんね強くてもね私にいいと思うよ
ん
眉毛もちゃんと入った相撲は指摘だと思いますね
どうやってつけまつげなんですよねパパとれたみようか助けねこれ色が来た来たぜ
あこちらはなってきたできたできた新たな米亀がおかしい
あなんかおかしいよねやっぱりマイヤーその9月末いけば釣りです
いかに命の周りを綺麗に見せるかが勝負で体のラインやにこう入れることでかお金
小さく見えるって朝日なんか言ってた後大変になってきてるチークが強くなって
いただきますよ唇にちょっとチャイムを入れてこうチョコを食いかけてたみたいなお
茶目な感じも入れていきたいですねをが少
って気がするけど完成ですどうかしらぁて早速先輩と友達とか言ってみましょう
[音楽]
持ち上げん
います
[拍手]